[Music]
Godzilla's first enemy in the
monsterverse both in prehistoric ages
and in the modern times isn't the mutos
it is a very peculiar and ancient
monster that is different from all the
other Tiant that have been seen on
screen and in the comics this of course
is the shinamura seen in the comics
Godzilla aw Awakening it is seen as a
great and ominous threat to the planet
it had the potential to be so much more
and could have been an overarching
Global threat in the monsterverse but
was killed off by the combined efforts
of Godzilla and the US military in the
end of the comics so here in this video
we will explain its biology and life
cycle and why it could have been the
deadliest Titan in the monster universe
so let's get to
it let's start with its Origins and
history this mysterious super species
with with the name shinomura is derived
I mean the name is derived from the
Japanese phrase called shamur
translating to the ominous phrase the
swarm of death shinamura evolved
alongside Godzilla back at least 250
million years ago this creature was said
to be both a parasite and a competitor
of Godzilla and they both hated each
other it wasn't until that natural order
was disrupted by the peran Triassic
Extinction event by a meteor crashing
into the Earth acting as a turning point
in the planet's history that it was
during this time that the shinamura the
last one was almost at the point of
being wiped out of existence by Godzilla
that instead it found itself plch
underground entering a dorant slumber
for millions of
years and it wasn't until the fateful
day of the bombing of hero Shima that
the ancient creature stirred from its
eon's long stases probably energized and
resurrected by the radiation of the atom
bombs of World War II this cataclysmic
event acted as a catalyst rousing
shinamura from a subterranean layer and
over the span of several years 9 years
to be exact it grew from being a
harmless dorant colony of cells to a
larger predatory variant and then slowly
over time grew to a Titanic flying
monster it was also at that time at the
same time it was hunted by Godzilla who
might have inherited an instinct from
his ancestors to kill and subdue this
threat this super species which could
have brought about the end of the world
it met its end in the bikini atos with a
nuclear B from the castle bravoz that
was meant to kill both the Gman and that
swarm of death now let's take a short
look at the Titan design shinamura
primarily manifested as a colossal
winged creature reminiscent of massive
insects it boasted a formidable
appearance adorned with blue segmented
armor and endowed with expansive black
membranous wings sporting a total of six
luminous white eyes three on each side
of the head its body is serpent-like in
nature terminating in a scorpion-like
prehensile taale adding to its imposing
presence the mouth of shinamura was
composed of sharp plates supported by
exom manales occasionally emitting a
radiant white light from within as this
Titan grew larger two tendrils ending in
sharp ends emerg from its under belly
appearing like deadly
claws so as far as we can say there are
four life stages in its life cycle
firstly its cellular stage which as we
saw in the museum in the comics
Awakening was Domin and can grow rapidly
in a span of moments into a large
room-sized monster given enough
radiation energy the cell stage appears
to be a large black and blueish starfish
form and this cell is easily the size of
a watermelon the second stage is what we
will term as a juvenile form even though
there is no specific growth stages since
it is a super Colony species the
juvenile looks like a mutated wyvern
with two legs and two wings as well as a
set of six reddish eyes instead of the
white glowing eyes as seen in the bigger
Titan form its body also has sharp
protrusions at random areas as well as a
long tail with three for
endings now we come to the third stage
the Titan level Colony stage which as we
have described a minute ago is a
gigantic black and bluish flying
creature with segmented armor and six
white eyes by this time the Super Colony
has developed a serpentine form with a
scorpion-like tail and a pair of
tendrils that act as Claws by this stage
it was formidable enough to put up a
fight against Godzilla and even divide
and recombine into two speciments each
that act as a part of a single
individual therefore hinting at some
form of ESP connection between every
single of the billions of cells
coordinating to push for survival and to
thrive for this Titan
species the fourth stage now there is
also a theoretical super form which has
not been seen in the comics but was
hinted at in a passage or two it said
that if the shinamura was allowed to
continually feed on radiation if that
continued uninterrupted it can grow
until it blocks out the sky and this
will be too powerful for even Godzilla
to defeat it and since we saw it in the
flashback of the peran period of it
feeding on a Titan carcass it means that
all life on Earth will be its prey and
it will cause Extinction on a global
scale thus the shinamura represents a
collective entity formed from the fusion
of millions of cells akin to the nature
of destoya with A continuous supply of
radiation a lone cell possesses the
remarkable ability to regenerate into a
complete shinamura therefore it is
almost impossible to completely
eradicate it if a few cells would have
fallen off during battle and went into a
state of domancy again its complex
composition allows shinamura the
flexibility to also mold its unified
form as desired enabling the creation of
additional appendages such as menacing
tendrils acting as weapons so
functioning as a super organism
shinomura comprises of a myriad smaller
organisms that seamlessly unite to form
a singular cohesive body this unique
structure grants shinamura the capacity
to divide into multiple entities and
subsequently reassemble again and so as
seen in the comics quite many of the
cells have been acquired and stored by
Monarch therefore its end is neither
final nor is its Resurrection in the
future an impossibility if it was
somehow to find its way into the hollow
Earth to the energy source then it could
become a threat that is worthy of a big
screen
appearance so that's the end if you like
this video then watch this one as well
and if you're more interested in other
movie monsters and creatures then check
out our Channel as well we might just
have things that you haven't seen or
thought about like subscribe and we'll
see you on the next video till the next
one take care fam